katia bonjour quel est le programme de
la journée
[Musique]
alors ici il se déroule une action
festive de la part des agents de la
fonction publique qui veulent
sensibiliser un autre critère celui de
la pénibilité qui n'est selon eux pas
pris encore vraiment en considération
dans la nouvelle réforme dont il ya là
des égoutiers des dératiseurs des
éboueurs des agents de surveillance et
tous évidemment occupent des professions
qui ont des critères certains de
pénibilité pardon et la référence vie
pour un grand nombre est
considérablement réduite
jusqu'ici ils bénéficiaient ce qui
s'appelle le service actif qui leur
permettait de bénéficier de départs
anticipés cinq ou dix ans avant avant
l'âge légal
or les mesures de la réforme ne
maintiendraient le service active au
mieux que pour les professions à risque
je vous propose d'écouter deux d'entre
eux deux délégués syndicaux qui ne
parlent de leurs conditions de travail
et de leur inquiétude pour les égoutiers
par exemple c'est un départ prévu à 52
enfants
en tout cas une possibilité de
de partir à 52 ans pour les éboueurs les
conducteurs une possibilité de partir à
57 ans et aujourd'hui on nous dit on va
allonger et cette pénibilité les plus
reconnus et juste juste il ya deux
enquêtes qui ont été faites par par des
chercheurs sur sur la mort de deux des
égoutiers par exemple ses 17 ans 17 ans
de vie en moins chez les égoutiers que
n'importe quel ouvrier en france et on a
le même comparatif pour les éboueurs
parisiens
on essaye de négocier au niveau 2 de la
ville de paris mais c'est un peu
compliqué dans le sens où ils vont dans
le sens du gouvernement et il essaye
d'appliquer les dernières lois notamment
celles de la transformation de la
fonction publique et celle des retraites
à venir donc ici elle les agents de la
fonction publique se sont allongés à
l'arrière on ne peut pas les voir d'ici
mais vous aurez les images ils sont
allongés par terre sur une scène de
crime celle qui a été déployée par la
police scientifique pour signifier bien
évidemment que leur profession est comme
mise à mort en fait avec la nouvelle
retraite il ne pourrait partir que deux
ans avant l'âge légal et la possiblité
impossibilité d'être à temps partiel en
percevant une partie de leur retraite ne
serait ouverte qu'à soixante deux ans à
partir de 62 ans
donc voici pourquoi les agents
aujourd'hui sont en colère à propos de
ce manque de considération de la
pénibilité
merci katia pour ces précisions